[Musique]
on m'a demandé plusieurs fois de faire
des visites des sites du 11 septembre
j'ai refusé pendant longtemps parce que
je voulais pas gai de touristes et que
la nouvelle tour numéro un et new
yorkais depuis des décennies de noix
gendron a longtemps évité le quartier de
lower manhattan où s'élevaient les tours
jumelles du world trade center
qu'on m'a convaincu de venir faire des
guides et je me suis rendu compte que ça
m'a aidé à reconnecter avec ces
événements-là de police pas les éviter
mais à regarder aller au-delà du premier
avion du deuxième avion de
l'effondrement d'enlever cette triste
c'est celle qui s'est effondré l'immense
tristesse causée par l'attentât
qu'étudier presque 3000 personnes a fait
place à un autre sentiment ça évoque la
guérison
quand d'édifices love s'était également
un raz-de-marée de débris qui
différaient à tout prix qu'offre
verluise de noix gendron on commence ses
tours guidés dans cette chapelle déjà
réputé pour avoir survécu à des
incendies parce qu'elle a échappé au
pire il y a vingt ans derrière un
carreau d'une fenêtre c'est tout c'est
tout un seul corps robin preneur sur ses
grilles on pouvait lire des messages
laissés entre autres par des parents des
enfants des frères des soeurs
désespéré sans nouvelles de leurs
proches
[Musique]
pour parler du trou béant moi je n'ai
jamais vu comme la plupart des new
yorkais d'abord parce que de façon
subconsciente on évitait le quartier ce
quartier de la haute finance incarnation
du capitalisme qui en est fait une cible
de choix pour les terroristes est devenu
un symbole de mort le 11 septembre 2001
la plupart des gens ne le voient pas
comme le lieu de sépulture
il voit quand même mais mourir l'eau
représente nos larmes en souvenir des
victimes on peut lire leur nom au tour
des deux bassins construit sur les lieux
des tours jumelles si vous apercevez une
rose blanche et ferrer 9e non c'est pour
nous dire que aujourd'hui aurait été
l'anniversaire de naissance de cette
personne une famille ailleurs 6 millions
personnes par année cubaine l'obésité un
devoir de mémoire pour une tragédie que
les moins de vingt ans ne peuvent pas
connaître on va voir beaucoup d'ados
avec leur téléphone qu'il faut des
selles fille avec les grands
les grands sourires ou dessus des
piscines moi ça me dérange mais on peut
pas leur en vouloir il n'était pas là
ils savent pas ce que c'est ils ont
besoin ils ont besoin d'aidé du quai
cet arbre retrouvés vivants mais
fortement endommagés sous les débris de
grande 0 est présenté comme un exemple
de résilience c'est la fête chaussures
vécu les événements du 11 septembre des
survivants participe à l'occasion au
tour guidé de benoît gendron il sent
chez les visiteurs un besoin de boucler
la boucle et se sent obligé de me dire
ce qu'ils ont fait est là on s'étonne
comment ils n'ont vécu j'ai jamais ça
quand je fais la statue de la liberté
mais je le dis ici c'est comme un lieu
où tout le monde est pour communier et
puis on s'échange des histoires la
reconstruction se poursuit sur le site
qui a recommencé à vivre sous une
nouvelle forme et de nouveaux visages
avec une variété d'entreprises qui ont
choisi de s'installer dans cette tour
surnommé freedom tower
ça m'a jamais effleuré mais jamais
pleurer vous ai jamais fait à l'idée de
partir de mur parce qu'il tenait à
participer à la renaissance de la grosse
pomme dont les résidents ont changé lui
aussi dit il énormément différent
je fais le test des fois avec les gens
qui viennent à la visite guidée je leur
demande combien d'entre vous sont à new
york avant le ronde cet art c'était quoi
votre impression des new yorkais sont
las ils sont artistes parlent pas ils
semblent
maintenant
c'est quoi votre votre réaction face à
ces différents ils sont gentils
en ce vingtième anniversaire des
attentats qui ont endeuillé la ville et
les états unis le new yorkais d'adoption
résume ainsi ce que lui inspire ce site
emblématique
l'état donne c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment